[Music]
there's a mistake moonlight you guys won
best picture holy cow that's quite it
quite a thing that was an unbelievable
thing take us through how you found out
and you know moment by moment as it was
developing we don't where we're so
confused
there was a so there suddenly appeared a
guy on the stage you know one of the
guys with the headset yeah and he
started looking for the envelope because
it felt like something was wrong and I
don't think anybody really knew because
we were still sort of having our
celebration and accepting and he asked
for the envelope that I was holding that
I had been given when I walked up there
and he opened it and it said Emma Stone
la-la-land how that happened I have no
idea but then a search for the correct
envelope I guess I don't know it just
sort of appeared in his hand and it's
that best picture on it and he opened it
and I said moonlight I'm gonna be really
proud to hand this to my friends for
moonlight we've become incredibly close
to those guys and like I honestly was an
honour to be able to give it to them did
you get a chance to talk to them I
haven't seen him yet but I'm looking
forward to finding them and giving them
big hugs again you handled it better
than anybody could have ever handled
that situation it could have been the
most difficult situation you could even
conceive of it at the Oscar it was a
difficult situation there's no doubt
about that but it was listening things
get thrown at you and you got to kind of
roll with it and as I said I was I was
deeply happy to be able to give it to to
those guys that really I don't know I so
I'm a little it's shocking and I'm a
little bit of loss for words
[Music]
you